[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
guten Abend und willkommen den Sport in
der Sendung präsentiert Christian Otto
ein bunten Mix guten Abend wir haben
unter anderem diese Themen für Sie
grünes Licht fürs heizungsgesetz die
Ampel einigt sich auf Fördersätze und
auf Grenzen für die Kostenbelastung für
Mieter
Razzia beim Kardinal hat der Kölner
Erzbischof Wölki vor Gericht einen
Meineid geleistet
und Drogentod mit 13 in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben Dealer
hochdosierte Ecstasy-Pillen an Kinder
verkauft
[Musik]
das umstrittene heizungsgesetz kann wohl
doch noch vor der Sommerpause
verabschiedet werden eine Nachtsitzung
der Fraktionsspitzen hat offenbar einen
Durchbruch gebracht die FDP betont
niemand werde verpflichtet seine Heizung
auszubauen
ein paar Details sind schon
durchgesichert
durchgesickert so soll es generell einen
Zuschuss von 30% geben wenn man eine
klimafreundliche Heizung einbaut der
Zuschuss kann sich für
einkommensschwache Haushalte auf bis zu
70 Prozent erhöhen und ab dem Jahr 2029
soll dem Erdgas regenerativ
hergestelltes Gas beigemischt werden das
bodensack berichtet
welche Heizung muss wann Vio mit welcher
Unterstützung eingebaut werden um dem
Klima noch rechtzeitig zu helfen diese
Fragen haben die Ampelkoalition nahe ans
Scheitern gebracht jetzt scheint der
Streit wohl endgültig beigelegt für die
SPD hat das Gesetz ein deutlich
sozialeren Anstrich bekommen wir haben
die Förderkulisse noch mal wesentlich
erweitert wer wenige hat bekommt mehr
und das bis zu 70 Prozent wir haben ganz
explizit die Mieterinnen und Mieter
geschützt jetzt in unserer
Konkretisierung und zwar das
Mieterhöhungen durch diesen
heizungsumtausch maximal 50 Cent pro
Quadratmeter betragen dürfen die FDP
dagegen betont dass die Vermieter 10%
der Kosten für den Austausch der Heizung
auf die Mieter umlegen können und sieht
sich in ihrem monatelangen in der
Koalitionären Widerstand bestätigt es
war wichtig dass wir diese Debatte die
auch öffentlich sehr stark geführt wurde
und auch zurecht geführt wurde die die
Menschen sehr stark verunsichert hat
dass wir uns als Parlament jetzt sehr
verantwortungsvoll dieser Aufgabe
gestellt haben und auch die Bedenken die
er ernst zu nehmen sind aufgenommen
haben und jetzt im Gesetzentwurf auch
maßgebliche Änderungen herbeiführen
damit die Menschen nicht überfordert
werden die Union kritisiert das Vorgehen
der Ampel scharf
nach monatelangem Streit mutet die Ampel
dem Parlament ein wochenendgesetz so
wenige Stunden Zeit um über
weitreichende Änderungen zu beraten das
ist zu wenig wir kennen noch keine Texas
ein blindfug der da gestartet wird noch
fehlen die konkreten Formulierungen des
Gesetzes aber bereits übernächste Woche
soll es im Bundestag verabschiedet
werden
zwei Tage hat es gedauert bis der Kreml
auf die abgebrochene Revolte im eigenen
Land reagierte jetzt heißt es Präsident
Putin sei keineswegs durch den Aufstand
der wagnergruppe geschwächt Putin selbst
sprach von einem Bürgerkrieg den die
Sicherheitskräfte verhindert hätten der
Chef der Söldnergruppe prigoshi soll
mittlerweile in Belarus sein Sebastian
eben hat mehr
mit Verzögerung ist die PR-Maschine des
Kreml voll angelaufen Wladimir Putin
meldete sich mehrmals bin in weniger
Stunden zu Wort bei einer
Gedenkveranstaltung spricht er vom
glorreichen Einsatz der
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die wagnergruppe
die er Verräter nennt
unsere Waffenbrüder die Piloten starben
bei der Konfrontation mit den Rebellen
sie haben nicht gezögert und haben ihre
Befehle und ihre militärische Pflicht
ehrenvoll erfüllt
putin will der Welt jetzt vor allem eins
zeigen er hatte auch während des
Aufstands alles unter Kontrolle der
Präsident gibt heute erstmals zu dass
die wagnergruppe mit über 900 Millionen
Euro aus Staatsmitteln finanziert wurde
sind ihre jenny ist die finanzielle
Unterstützung der gesamten wagnergruppe
hat vollständig der Staat übernommen
am Nachmittag ist Wagner Chef Jewgeni
priogin in Minsk angekommen das
bestätigt der belarussische Präsident
Alexander Lukaschenko der sich heute vor
laufenden Kameras für seine erfolgreiche
Vermittlung zwischen bregorian und Putin
brüstet offen und selbstbewusst spricht
er darüber wie er den wagner-chef in
seinen Sicherheitsapparat einbinden
können
wenn die Wagner Kommandeure zu uns
kommen und uns helfen ist das eine gute
Erfahrung sie kämpfen an vorderster
Front das sind Sturmtruppen sie werden
und sagen was im Moment wichtig ist
unklar was er damit meint doch Putin
dürften diese Worte nicht gefallen
Lukaschenko will eng mit einem Mann
zusammenarbeiten den Putin öffentlich
zum Verräter erklärt hatte
hat Putin die Fäden noch in der Hand
welchen Einfluss hat der Aufstand der
wagnergruppe auf den Ukraine kriegt
Antworten gibt es bei heute live um
19:30 Uhr in der ZDF Mediathek und auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
die Vereinten Nationen werfen Russland
einmal mehr Kriegsverbrechen vor mehr
als 800 Festnahmen von Zivilisten in der
Ukraine sein bisher dokumentiert fast
alle hätten von Folter berichtet 77
Menschen sein willkürlich hingerichtet
worden aber auch die Ukraine habe
Zivilisten festgenommen und misshandelt
wenn auch in weit geringerer Zahl an der
Front gehen die Kämpfe mit aller Härte
weiter Christian Volk
so sieht Krieg aus
Bilder veröffentlicht vom ukrainischen
Militär offenbar aus der Region bachmut
ukrainische Soldaten greifen russische
Schützengräben an ein bis zwei Kilometer
habe man die Front hier verschieben
können der Präsident zufrieden
unsere Soldaten sind in alle Richtungen
vorgedrungen das ist ein glücklicher Tag
ich wünsche den Jungs mehr solcher Tage
auch südlich von Bach Mut soll es
Vorstöße geben bei grasnogorovka in
einem Gebiet das seit 2014 von
russischen Separatisten besetzt ist doch
neben all den Erfolgsmeldungen auch
diese Bilder Russland stoppt wohl einen
ukrainischen Vormarsch spricht von
eigenen Erfolgen und ein Drittel der
westlichen Ausrüstung habe Kiew bereits
verloren schätzen Militärexperten
offensichtlich haben die Ingenieure der
Russen auch gut gearbeitet und Sperren
eingerichtet die eben aus Minen und
panzersparen bestehen die es den
Ukrainern auch schwer machen
substanzielle Fortschritte zu machen
die Region Bach mut ist mittlerweile zu
einer Mondlandschaft Zert und in den
kommenden Wochen könnte die gegen
Offensive der Ukraine heftiger werden
mehrere Brigaden mit hunderten Soldaten
warten noch auf ihren Einsatz an der
Front
dieser Krieg habe auch direkte
Auswirkungen in Afrika besonders in
Bezug aufgestiegene Lebensmittelpreise
das betonte Außenministerin baerbock
heute bei ihrem Besuch in Südafrika das
Land hat den russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine bislang nicht verurteilt im
August ist dort der russische Präsident
im Rahmen eines Gipfeltreffens
eingeladen aus Pretoria berichtet
Patricia Wiedemeier
es ist ein kurzer und kein leichter
Besuch zu groß sind die
Meinungsunterschiede beim Thema Ukraine
Krieg doch die Begrüßung von Annalena
baerburg durch ihre südafrikanische
Amtskollegin nali die pandor immerhin
herzlicher als erwartet Südafrika sieht
sich als neutral an enthielt sich bei
Abstimmungen in der UN bärburg versucht
immer wieder die eher
russlandfreundlichen Südafrikaner zu
überzeugen die Stimme Südafrikas hat
Gewicht in der Welt wenn das Land Nelson
Mandelas und Desmond Tutus sich gegen
Unrecht ausspricht hört die Welt zu
Südafrikas Präsident war kürzlich mit
einer afrikanischen Delegation in der
Ukraine und in Russland traf selenski
und Putin legte einen Friedensplan vor
bisher ohne Erfolg
das ist wohl ein Ergebnis dessen wie
sich Südafrika Verhalten hat denn es
gibt derzeit kaum jemanden außer uns der
mit beiden Seiten verhandeln kann wir
können Erfolg haben wir können scheitern
aber wir haben versucht Frieden zu
stiften
am Nachmittag dann ein spontanes langes
Treffen mit dem Präsidenten ramafosa den
Friedensprozess will er weiter
fortsetzen an der Haltung gegenüber
Russland wird es wohl nichts ändern
trotz aller Differenzen beim Thema
Russland betonen beide Länder auch
gemeinsame Interessen beim Klimaschutz
beim Handel und bei der Gleichstellung
es ist erklärte Ziel der ampelregierung
die Länder des globalen Südens mehr und
besser einzubinden da lohne sich auch
dieser Kurztrip nach Südafrika so die
Außenministerin auch deshalb fördert die
EU mit 8,5 Milliarden Euro die
Energiewende in Südafrika noch ist hier
Kohle der Haupt Energieträger
flächendeckende Stromausfälle sind die
Regel Rohstoffe für die Erneuerbaren
gibt es reichlich zumindest in dieser
Beziehung ist Südafrika für Deutschland
ein verlässliches Partnerland
eine Razzia in Räumlichkeiten eines
Kardinals das ist eher selten die heute
war nach Angaben der Staatsanwaltschaft
alternativlos im Mittelpunkt steht der
Kölner Kardinal Woelki und der Verdacht
der Falschaussage vor Gericht es geht um
die Frage ob welche davon wusste dass
einem Priester des Bistums sexueller
Missbrauch vorgeworfen wird Peter Böhmer
der Kölner Kardinal Woelki öffnete den
Ermittlern heute morgen selbst die Tür
Durchsuchungen der Staatsanwaltschaft
mit 30 Beamten in sechs Objekten unter
anderem der erzbischöflichen Residenz es
geht um den Vorwurf des Meineids und der
falschen eidesstattlichen Versicherung
inhaltlich geht es dabei im Wesentlichen
jeweils um die Frage ob Kardinal Wölke
überhaupt und wenn ja zu welchem
konkreten Zeitpunkt Kenntnis von gegen
zwei Kleriker erhobenen
Missbrauchsvorwürfen hatte
im März vor Gericht unter Eid ausgesagt
Details zu den Vorwürfen gegen einen
beschuldigten Priester nicht gekannt zu
haben zuvor hatte er 2021 im selben Fall
eine eidesstattliche Erklärung abgegeben
der Mann war von Bürki befördert worden
auch in einem anderen Fall will wirken
nichts von Missbrauchsvorwürfen gewusst
haben
das Erzbistum reagierte bisher nur per
Pressemitteilung auf die Razzia
erfahrungsgemäß wird es geraume Zeit in
Anspruch nehmen bis das Ergebnis
vorliegt bis dahin bitten wir die
Öffentlichkeit eine ergebnisoffene
Untersuchung nicht zum Anlass zu nehmen
Vorverurteilungen auszusprechen
Kardinal Woelki hatte bisher sämtliche
Vorwürfe zurückgewiesen bisher ist es
nur ein Anfangsverdacht doch die Razzia
heute in Köln zeigt dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft die Vorwürfe durchaus
ernst nimmt sollten Sie sich bestätigen
und Kardinal Wölke in einem möglichen
Prozess tatsächlich Meineid nachgewiesen
werden können droht ihm meine Haftstrafe
von mindestens einem Jahr der
Missbrauchskandal in Köln mit einem
weiteren Kapitel das Bistum kommt aus
den Schlagzeilen nicht heraus
der Hass gegen Jüdinnen und Juden in
Deutschland bleibt ein großes
gesellschaftliches Problem das zeigt die
Zahl der gemeldeten antisemitischen
Vorfälle im vergangenen Jahr zählte der
Bundesverband der Recherche und
Informationsstellen Antisemitismus
2480 Fälle das heißt im Schnitt gibt es
pro Tag fast 7 registrierte
Beleidigungen Sachbeschädigungen
Bedrohungen oder gewalttätige Angriffe
und noch ein Jahresbericht wer zum
Beispiel bei der Arbeit oder bei der
Wohnungssuche diskriminiert wird kann
sich bei der
Antidiskriminierungsstelle des Bundes
melden im vergangenen Jahr sind
insgesamt
8.827 Anfragen eingegangen so viele wie
nie zuvor das sind 14 Prozent mehr als
im Vorjahr die Menschen berichteten am
häufigsten über rassistische
Diskriminierungen 43 Prozent
Diskriminierung aufgrund einer
Behinderung Beklagten 27% wegen des
Geschlechts 21 Prozent und wegen des
Alters zehn Prozent mehrfachnennungen
waren möglich
vor acht Jahren flog die
abgasmanipulation an Millionen von Autos
auf heute ist erstmals ein früherer
Manager des VW-Konzerns wegen Betrugs
verurteilt worden
Ex-Chef Stadler erhielt ebenso wie zwei
mit Angeklagte eine Bewährungsstrafe
plus Geldstrafe alle drei hatten einen
Vorschlag des Gerichts akzeptiert sie
legten Geständnisse ab dafür muss keiner
ins Gefängnis Alexander Pool und Peter
auch Meyer
fast unbemerkt verlässt Robert Stadler
am Abend das Gerichtsgebäude nach 172
Prozesstagen als freier Mann und doch
ist der einst so erfolgreiche Manager
heute verurteilt worden als erster
Vorstandschef im dieselskandal ein Jahr
und neun Monate auf Bewährung dazu eine
Geldauflage von 1,1 Millionen Euro
das Gericht hat sehr detailliert erklärt
warum es im Ergebnis davon ausgeht dass
Audi hier unerlaubte
abschaltvorrichtungen verwendet hat und
warum die Angeklagten jeweils davon
wussten bzw dies auch veranlasst haben
und dies nachdem sie es wussten nicht
verhindert haben im Falle des
Angeklagten ehemaligen
Vorstandsvorsitzenden des Unternehmens
der dieselskandal beschäftigt die Justiz
seit Jahren eine spezielle Software
sorgte auch in vielen Audi Modellen
dafür dass diese auf dem Prüfstand
weniger Schadstoffe ausschließen als im
Straßenverkehr erst nach langem Zögern
gab Robert Stadler Mitte Juni zu von
dieser Manipulation gewusst zu haben
statt lass Verteidigung nach dem
heutigen Urteil erleichtert
nach der über sechs Stunden
Urteilsverkündung sind wir jetzt erstmal
zufrieden dass das Verfahren zu Ende ist
und dass der Stader seine Freiheit
erhalten haben konnte der Schaden aus
dem dieselskandal beläuft sich allein
für Audi auf rund 2,7 Milliarden Euro
Stadler ist mit Rechtskraft des Urteils
ein vorbestrafter Betrüger das Gericht
ist davon überzeugt Stadler wusste von
der abgasmanipulation und hat nichts
dagegen unternommen damit trägt der
Schuld am Betrug an Millionen Audi
Käufern mit dem Urteil gegen Rupert
Stadler geht eines der prominentesten
Verfahren im dieselskandal zu Ende
hände weg von Drogen möchte man rufen
angesichts der Tragödie in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern eine 13-Jährige
ist tot eine 14-Jährige kämpft in der
Klinik um ihr Leben einer 15-Jährigen
geht es etwas besser die jungen Mädchen
haben wohl das gleiche genommen eine
hoch dosierte Ecstasy Pille namens Blut
Panne gegen einen 37-jährigen wurde
haftbefehlern lassen Bernd Mosebach hat
mehr
das Mädchen schwebt den Lebensgefahr als
es gestern im Neubrandenburger Klinikum
eingeliefert wird am Nachmittag stirbt
die 13-Jährige klinische Tests zeigen
sie hatte Ecstasy konsumiert dann ist
wenig später gestern eine 14-Jährige in
die Klinik eingeliefert worden die
ebenfalls starke Symptome aufweist und
auch in kritischem Zustand ist und
zusätzlich ist noch eine 15-jährige seit
vergangener Woche bereits in der Klinik
die ebenfalls immer noch im kritischen
Zustand ist am Wochenende war eine
15-jährige in Brandenburg nach Konsum
von Drogen gestorben die Ermittler
schließen an den Zusammenhang nicht aus
das ist die Droge um die es geht exte
sie eine synthetische Droge und eine
besonders gefährliche Variante davon
blue Punisher vermutlich extrem hoch
dosiert die Folgen des Konsums können
dramatisch sein Ausbrüche kriege ich ein
Horror-Trip habe oder das eben mein
Körper austrocknet weil er sehr erhitzt
ist das Herzrasen und das ist eben zu
leben und Nierenversagen und damit auch
zum Tot ankommen kann die Dosis ist
entscheidend das gefährliche keine
Konsumenten kann erkennen wie viel
Wirkstoff enthalten ist das ist das
große Problem es wird halt nicht unter
klinischen
Voraussetzungen hergestellt sondern in
illegalen Laboren die Ermittlungen auch
im Umfeld der Mädchen brachten erste
Erfolge vier Männer im Alter von 16 bis
37 Jahren wurden vorläufig festgenommen
gegen den älteren wurde am Nachmittag
Haftbefehl erlassen
jetzt zum Sport zum Segeln einmal um die
Welt aber nun ist das spektakuläre Ocean
Race ein halbes Jahr Abenteuer großartig
es ist halt also geschafft der Kampf mit
den Naturgewalten auf hoher See die
letzte Etappe etwas mehr als 11 Tage
lang von Den Haag nach Genua wann Boris
Hermann mit seiner Crew auf der malizia
ein toller Showdown
die letzten Meilen bis ins Ziel vor
Genua waren eine harte Geduldsprobe für
Boris Herrmann und seine Crew erst in
den letzten Stunden des Rennens schoben
sie sich an die Spitze und sicherten
sich den zweiten Etappen Sieg zum
Abschluss der Jubiläumsausgabe des Ocean
Racers
verändert schon mein Leben das erste Mal
dass ich beim Ocean Race dabei bin eine
alte Legende 50 Jahre alt ein ja eine
der
gipfelveranstaltung des Segelsports 31
000 Seemeilen rund um den Globus 6
Monate sieben Etappen zwei davon
gewonnen darunter die härteste durch
Südpolarmeer erster am Kap Horn dazu
einen 24 Stunden
geschwindigkeits-weltrekord aufgestellt
die Liste der Folge vom Thema ist lang
genau wie die anlegeparty heute hier in
Genua
haben sie verdient auf einen sogenanntes
Fußballwunder auf die deutsche U21
Mannschaft bei der EM in Butan Georgien
fakt ist morgen zählt nur ein Sieg gegen
England plus Unterstützung von Israel um
im Turnier zu bleiben eine große
Herausforderung
Stürmer yusufa moukuko wird wohl nicht
mitwirken können nahm kleinen
Fußballwunder seine Muskelverletzung ist
noch nicht ausgeheilt seine
Mannschaftskollegen hingegen wollen
gegen den em mit Favoriten England
kämpfen bis zum Umfallen und aus dem
Tschechien Spiel lernen nämlich morgen
die herausgespielten Chancen auch nutzen
unsere Prinzipien die gelten auch jetzt
wir wollen mutig nach vorne spielen wir
suchen auch den Weg nach vorne Siegen
und gleichzeitig hoffen auf die
Schützenhilfe von Israel lautet die
Devise sonst geht's bereits nach der
Gruppenphase nach Hause
wichtiger Erfolg für das deutsche
Tischtennis mixteam dann zu und Nina
Mittel haben bei den European Games in
Krakau durch den klaren 13:0 Erfolg im
Endspiel gegen das ungarische Duden und
Dora mataracter schafften sie die
Qualifikation für die Olympischen
Sommerspiele kommendes Jahr in Paris
Zack und schon haben sie das Ticket in
der Tasche es geht schneller danke schön
Christine morgen gibt's noch mal ein
bisschen Regen dann beruhigt sich das
Wetter wieder die Details hat gleich als
den terli im heutigen Journal um 9:45
Uhr spricht Mallorca mit Außenministerin
bärbock hier übernimmt morgen mit Sirin
ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter kräftige Gewitter
gab es heute im Nordosten mit der
einfließenden kühleren Luft ansonsten
sehen wir noch etwas anderes auf diesem
Bild nämlich rauchschwaren die von den
Bränden von Nordamerika stammen und
Richtung Portugal und Spanien gezogen
sind die erreichen uns dann am
Donnerstag und Freitag auch in
Deutschland in der nachts gibt es in der
Südhälfte Regen der zieht aus südwärts
sonst ist es größtenteils trocken bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von 9 bis 15 Grad
und morgen gibt es Schauer im
Tagesverlauf im Osten im Süden muss der
Regen aus der Nacht erstmal verschwinden
genauso wie im Westen aber dann lockerts
auf und die Sonne kommt hervor weil
höchsten Temperaturen von 27 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands und 20 Grad z.B
an der Nordsee in den nächsten Tagen
kommen weitere Schauer und Gewitter auf
am Donnerstag schon vom Westen her weil
23 bis 30 Grad und am Freitag überqueren
Sie uns allmählich ostwärts und am
Samstag ist es dann ein wenig kühler und
damit ein schöner Abend